Oh
[Music]
I've never seen you so happy so all the
boys I've loved before the rom-com hit
that's got everybody swooning over
breakout star Noah sent to neo
aren't you guys obsessed with him too
well with another Netflix movie on the
way Noah has quickly become the
Internet's boyfriend and is assuring in
the next wave of the teen heartthrob so
what does he make of all the attention
well our point has no found out so just
like these love letters are out now your
movies are out how are you reacting to
being the newest heartthrob just hanging
out and I hope I hope not a lot does
change I'll say the same thing I kind of
said before an anticipation was like the
outer world is gonna change for sure and
like whether it's more people knowing
who I am or more jobs coming in but like
I want my inner space to stay the same
right and that's really important to me
I mean with all this buzz it's it sounds
like you're a little bit of a private
person like you love to have like that
family time and whatnot would you say
that about yourself yes yeah so this
like when people are in your diems
and are sending you all these wild
tweets I mean do you ignore them are you
responding what's like your your thing
to stay grounded most part I I kind of
just don't even really look at it now
before there was Noah it's almost as if
each decade had a teen heartthrob the
80s had Rob Lowe but could we talk about
the 90s because the 90s were lit and I'm
Jonathan Taylor Thomas
we watched jtt grow up on home
improvement every morning it's like wow
is this you know it is really happening
am I really fortunate yeah am I really
this lucky to be working on you know the
number one TV show in America and then
his career exploded right now just
trying to you know get my roots planted
and as many fields as I can
you know just experience everything then
we got devon Sawa who co-starred in wild
America with jtt sister hey
he also lit up the big screen in now and
then little giants and Casper I told you
I was a good dancer
[Music]
who could forget Freddie Prinze jr. who
started several teen movies including
she's all that Villani listen I was
wondering maybe you'd want it let's go
Simon embarrass me horribly he also
starred in scooby-doo and I know what
you did last summer alongside now wife
Sarah Michelle Gellar the couple shares
two kids together look for the record
this wasn't my idea
and Freddy's been focused on voiceover
work lately he's also open to watching
as she's all that remix I wouldn't want
to be in it but I definitely ryan
philippi also starred and I know what
you did last summer
but solidified his heartthrob status in
cruel intentions guys they're gonna be
so jealous we're doing a photo shoot the
other day and just thought about how
many guys between the age of like 13 and
30 would have loved have been like you
know sitting in between Sarah and reason
he married and later divorced co-star
Reese Witherspoon they share two kids
together Deacon and Ava Kel Mitchell was
all that in the 90s he made us love more
soda
oh my god what do I do tell us now
married has three kids and still works
with Nickelodeon Sierra Burgess is a
loser is available on Netflix starting
September 7th and for more of our
interview with Noah that's up on ET
online.com are you guys we're starting
Labor Day weekend a date early so no day
lead any tomorrow we will be back next
Tuesday enjoy your long weekend I know I
will choose
[Music]